good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday it doesn't feel
like a Friday cause the banks gave us
Monday it really does not feel like a
Friday because the week was so short
and so full of joy and excitement to be
back in the saddle with my girl Jax it's
true but it tis Friday nonetheless the
days of the week continue on and that's
really exciting we made it through the
first week of the new year I think
pretty painlessly and it felt like a
good week I'm really excited for
everyone that we've reached this
Milestone congrats
congratulations
um it doesn't really feel like a Friday
for me because right after this like I'm
not headed into the weekend like I'm
headed into straight travel mode I'm
going to LA right after this I actually
have like a huge update on like my West
Coast so you're like going up and party
in La like I feel like that's exactly a
weekend feeling like you're hopping on a
flight you're going to a new city like
you're going to parties
no for sure but like getting on a plane
for six hours is not like weekend
relaxation Friday afternoon Vibes you
know it's getting you to your fun-filled
weekend
you know and my weekend like of course
everything being planned so last minute
um
but I've made it I've made a decision
and I need the toaster's help I need
your help what is it
so you know I was telling everyone
that's why I'm wearing red today
um just show support for my favorite
team the 49ers I'm headed to the West
Coast and I've been meaning to get out
to a 49ers game just to see see my guys
you know I sound like one of those girls
um and so there's a game this Sunday and
me and Ben were planning on going and
then me and Ben were talking yesterday
and this is this game on Sunday is the
last game before the playoffs the 49ers
have already cinched a seat so they're
whether they win or lose this game it
doesn't matter the next week is a
playoff game so I'm still going to be on
the west coast next week and me and Ben
were like we should really just go next
week
so we've made the decision to not go to
the 49ers game this Sunday but next
weekend
um but there's a chance because I was
learning so much about football last
night so there's a chance that based on
the games that happened this weekend
that there might not be a 49ers game
next weekend it's called a bi weekend
the person who's in the number one seat
seed seed I don't know
gets a break it's called a bye week
before the playoffs so if the Eagles
lose to the Cowboys this Sunday then I
will have missed my opportunity to go to
a game now I I discussed with a couple
football experts and they said the
likelihood of the Eagles losing to the
Cowboys is extremely unlikely but
that's the nature of the game it's like
you never know what's going to happen
yeah that's why there is so to find out
right right so I'm taking a risk for
sure
are you asking me my opinion
I wasn't but I would but you accept it
you literally said like I need
everyone's help Jax I need your help
that's what you said at the beginning
yeah in help I was more so just like
setting up positive vibes to the Eagles
oh I can't though
I'm like because because I'm a Cowboys
fan
I'm a Cowboys fan are they playing the
cat but they're playing the Giants you
just have been saying the Cowboys this
entire time
hmm that's interesting it's the Giants
but the reason I said the Cowboys
because if the Cowboys do something else
it affects it as well but as long as the
Eagles win I'm good okay I just don't
you didn't ask me for my opinion so I'm
gonna keep my thoughts no I know what
you're gonna say negative Queen but
ghosts I would say like one you should
go to the guaranteed game that actually
works out better for your schedule which
is this weekend no it doesn't it doesn't
sure it's not like the Super Bowl of
games but everyone will be relaxed it's
kind of just like you know a scrimmage
you know that even if they lose they'll
be happy if they win they'll be happy
and you're going there to hang out with
happy people like what if the game next
week God forbid the Niners losing like
nobody wants to party with you after I
would go to the bird in the hands
like seriously shut up like okay first
of all it doesn't work with my schedule
this weekend like it was going to be
really difficult for me to get to San
Francisco so if I can do like next week
is so much easier for me and it's a
playoff game like I'm going all the way
like I should go I should stand for
something for sure
if you are like the biggest football fan
of all time but to us a football game a
football game is a football game
no honestly like seriously shut up like
stop like for real like because the
decision's already been made I'm going
next weekend
so I know like you know
like everyone who plays for the 49ers
was like expecting to see me this
weekend so I just wanted to come on the
podcast and know and like let them know
like I will be at the next game not this
one got it okay
okay cool
and I feel good about my decision like
I'm traveling cross-country like I need
to like I want to go to something major
and even if we're gonna win because the
49ers really at this point have never
let me down
um and I do believe it's their time to
win the playoffs I do it's a hundred
percent their time
100 but even if they don't
I still will feel like I showed support
for my team at a time that mattered when
they needed you
know the worst case scenario here is
that there's no game
oh then I'll be so [ __ ] annoyed that
like I missed but you know what
then it wasn't meant to be
but then I have to wait till next season
to go to a game
I support your decision
I feel like the eagles are going to pull
it out it's like when your mans are
watching
um football this weekend just make sure
you're root for the Eagles like positive
energy for the Eagles and now that I've
told you all this be like wow it would
be so crazy if the Eagles lose because
then the 49ers get a bye weekend like
you could like use all this jargon that
I've learned I I did it for you guys and
where do the Cowboys come in
such important questions
um
I'm not sure okay but there's an element
of the Cowboys but if the if the Eagles
win like we're good we're good we're
good if the Eagles win the 49ers will be
playing the Eagles
no no it I I thought the same thing by
the way no no because that would make
sense
no yeah no because honestly like I get
it I can't explain it to you it's one of
those things like I understand it I
couldn't verbalize it if I wanted to who
will the 49ers be playing if
there's a game next weekend
another incredible question that I have
no answers to and I want to say the
Jaguars the Jaguars it's my home state
don't talk [ __ ] right yeah I wasn't
talking to such a jaguars girly
God
sinclaudeville Jacksonville Claude
Jackson claudeville is better Jackson
claudeville Jaggers we could literally
know any team our team
well that's the unique ability that we
have to make anything about us yeah
because we're just really flexible and
open-minded
the New England
the Patriots
we're Patriots we're literally Patriots
I thought I thought we were like
literally putting our names in teams no
no we're just finding like an
association and a kinship with the team
yeah personally I like the Arizona
Arizona Cardinals the mclareness the
Cardinals that's kind of like my
favorite team you know yeah there are so
many great teams
so true
I also like the white jocks
the white chocolate
the white chocolate they're really good
but also the Boston Red Sox and Claude
are so good they're good too and we do
like red because we're also 49ers fans
right and that's why I'm wearing my
cherry red today ready to get my Brock
on so just send me Positive Vibes
because if I [ __ ] this up and like
fumble the ball never like actually get
to go to a game this season after
learning like literally everyone who
plays for the 49ers works for the 49ers
is obsessed with the toes and like I
don't even get to go to a place where
everyone's obsessed with me like I'll be
devastato I think it will work in your
favor you're just it's a little risky
but you know you gotta risk it to get
the biscuit the biscuit no I and maybe
adding to my list of resolutions like
I'm also taking risks whoa whoa whoa
because you know I'm a very conservative
girly like I'm usually just like you
know go with the safe option one in the
hand two in the bush the whole thing but
like why let's [ __ ] up the bush
until the bush [ __ ] you up
until you burn the bush down until you
wish you took the one in the hand that's
the lesson you got to learn the hard way
yeah I've got too much we could lose we
could learn it another time
100 yeah plus we need our toast
representative to go and show face you
know shake hands kiss babies let the
49ers know and the people of San
Francisco that we are here for them
okay now you're understanding like what
what I've been dealing with for the last
24 hours
no I I do understand why you're dealing
with your weekend it sounds so so fun
but for me like the first scrimmage fake
game sounds just as fun because it's
just a game
no and I guess what I'm trying to say is
like I feel like you know people look at
us they look at me and they think oh
such an easy life I'm making this look
easy like I'm actively making it look
easy like this is like these decisions
that weigh on me
oh my God I could just get emotional
talking about it it's exhausting choices
man
choices just like Audrina Patrick's book
is that what it was called I think so
choices choices
better than spare better than no choices
so true actually like love a queen who
makes choices yeah but on I disagree
about better than spare you know I think
it's a strong
I know we there were you told me this
morning that like every single story on
every single website is more excerpts
more drama I have respectfully asked
that we not I know we won't but just
take it like go to page six you don't
even have to click on not you Claudia
listener you don't have to click on an
article even though headlines are often
misleading just the volume of these
headlines and also the minutia like
Harry had frostbite on his dick at his
wedding like it's he's sharing if like
everything that's ever happened to him
in his life every feeling it's insane
yeah it's a little um TMI
a hundred percent I'm just I'm fatigued
by it also because yesterday I had the
pristine honor of being a guest on the
good guys podcast which will come out
next week and they wanted to do like a
little pop culture so of course like
everyone they were asking me about Harry
and Megan I had to explain it because
they like they don't get they don't know
the level that we know
and I was just I'm exhausted by these
two like I I feel like I'm just
constantly learning things about them
unwillingly like against my will I just
I think this book is a mistake I think
everything else they put forward it's
been like there's two sides and two
camps of people who like have their back
and people who don't but like this is
like crossed a line for sure it's more
level of detail than I ever need to know
about anyone's life period
period I'm so if he was a woman he'd be
telling us his period Cycles that's how
he'd be the kind of inflor that's like
not feeling the best today have my
period he'd be the kind of influer
influer yeah it's you just dropped the
scene yeah I dropped the C because
you're the C cool
oh my god
um so we aren't going to be discussing
that today thankfully we do have five
stories we're hoping that while we
record we're recording a little early
today because of my flight we're hoping
that we will get the sentencing from Jen
shot because if not we have to wait till
Monday which is so annoying
um I actually have a friend down at the
courthouse boots on the ground I'll be
getting you know information as it comes
in even though she had to turn her phone
off but still I'm really hoping that by
the time we get to the fifth Story that
it'll be here
are you going to be actually getting it
from her or no okay cool that's just
like she's just there just a fun fact
no she said there's a lot of cameras
outside it's crazy the cameras will
capture it
but I'm sure honestly even if she could
like text me as it was going on
literally the Press would get the people
notification would already be in your
inbox yeah so I'm waiting for my people
notification this is a crazy it's a
historic day honestly in the Bravo
Universe this is really crazy
yeah
and Meanwhile we're all sitting here
talking about Heather's black eye I
can't I'm not I feel good that I'm not
but like the culture you guys are
you guys are and that's on you because
in the words of Kim Kardashian you look
like [ __ ] clowns we're talking about
the playoffs which is just exciting to
behold
it's it's exciting I'm kind of loving
this like sports girl tomboy era that
we're in I feel like a real sports
influencer like people are not flocking
to our podcast and my Instagram being
like what does they think is going to
happen with the Eagles like it's just
it's kind of cool to be an expert in my
field you already are but to be an
expert in another field in another field
an additional literal field
it literally literally literally
literally
um so it's our final show of the week
what are your plans this weekend Jax
obviously I'm gonna be out gallivanting
but you're doing more important work
like raising the child of Christ yeah it
just will be home chilling mom Tings you
know maybe some crafts some fun
activities I do want to try and get to a
car dealership maybe today
oh exciting yeah because I I want to get
a car I don't like so I can start just
like doing the things that I need to do
and I have some appointments coming up
and I don't want to like be worried that
Zach's gonna have the car
so two questions for you one you know
people have been super helpful in giving
you feedback for like good mom cars have
you decided like a brand okay so I spoke
to the car mom extensively and I told
her I told her my thoughts and concerns
even though they're Flex oh yeah car mom
and I best friends we go way back we had
already spoken when uh Zach was getting
his car so now I just told her like what
I was looking for
um and we came up with like two good
choices for me and one of them is Alexis
and the other is a bobo so I'm gonna go
let me tell you I know the Ariel charna
says evolva yeah I'm gonna go to both
dealerships I think and test drive them
like get prices you know see how they
feel on the inside do my own like car
mom tests for like my lifestyle and I
think it will be between the two of
those
I'm not someone who needs to see every
car on the market no in order to make a
choice
when it comes to cars like I'm very much
a label [ __ ] so let me tell you what
the label says about about you if you if
you're interested in knowing what people
are going to be thinking Lexus IS older
it's elegant it's old money Lexus is
definitely old money like I like I don't
care you know yeah
um Volvo is so like I have brand
Association Volvo Ariel charnis Volvo
for me is like [ __ ] classy Rich mom
and that's about me is new new Young
Mama safe driving mama
that so are you looking for a mom car
because I thought you were looking for
like a punch buggy notebook no I'm not
looking for a punch Becky I am looking
I wasn't necessarily looking for uh mom
cart even though it will turn into if
I'm a mom and I'm sorry Zach's car is
your mom right but I don't want to use
it as the mom car like I don't like it
so I just have to say I like Zack's car
I I really don't uh so it's turned into
a mom card plus I do need something
heavy like I was saying how I wanted to
be in like some sort of mid-size sedan
um which I could like the cars that I'm
choosing are
mid-size sedan mom cars that are heavy
got it got it that are over 3000 pounds
well as your passenger princess I have
some requirements for for what I need
okay
seat heaters and coolers okay
a bevy
bevy
of cup holders
honestly I love a captain seat in the
back like I really I know there's so if
you want to have a lot of kids it's not
helpful and they're really not helpful
at all like we're always lapping up
Zach's car as captain seats like it's
nice when you're like in a car service
and they have captain seats but like
yeah for your actual and sometimes like
you want to sit next to the car seat you
want to sit in the middle seat and like
lean over the car seat you're losing a
whole lesson but like you want to play
like have access to the car seat and
play with your baby and I'm kind of like
I think captain seats are so elegant but
they're really not convenient I'm not
functional I'm not attached to them
okay I I think it's so classy and
elegant but I totally agree it's not
realistic it's not functional
it's not necessary
a brilliant sound system so that my 100
and toast can play for Harry on his way
to school or wherever he's going you
know he's so busy
um
I think that's it okay I will let the
dealer know
are you leaning towards a color like
black white is so Chic and very Florida
I'm less concerned about the color of
the outside I'm more concerned about the
color of the inside yeah if you're gonna
be making content from your car like you
want like a nice espresso or like a
beige attention I want a nice espresso
yeah I mean you're being very restrained
because like I don't have a car I've
never had a car and if the day ever came
like I'm getting a Rolls-Royce right no
like I'm getting the best of the best
yes and I understand that for you the
only reason why it's not that for me is
because I'm a new driver so like why
would I just like take money and maybe
be flushing it down the toilet no that's
that's a good point I need something uh
one like safe and reliable kid tested
you know everything
um but also like
it's my first carve
so true so okay I'm hoping to get to get
that
um to get that happen this week and I'm
hoping that when I go to the dealership
and they know that I'm like going to be
getting a car they like give me one for
you know a few days until like I get
before yours and then I just have a car
starting the day I go to the dealership
you know because sometimes they're like
that
no for sure like I feel as though you
know even though I've never bought a car
I do feel like when you walk into the
dealership like if you agree to buy the
car for them like they're going to take
care of you until you get the car right
and I will have a I'll have wheels
you'll have wheels on the bus going
round and round round and round round oh
my God I forgot to tell you
what
I forgot to tell you remember
we have made
communication
with Miss Rach
in what forum
she messaged us on Instagram
on the toast I responded last time
that's why I called you last night and I
couldn't remember work on your memory
work on it I know it's so bad I just
need to start leaving a pen and paper by
my nightstand you do she wrote thank you
guys with like a hundred hearts and
smiley emojis I guess she heard us
discussing her work
um earlier this week on the toast and
now that you know contact has been made
I feel like we're one step closer to
getting Miss rache on the toast which
would be such an iconic episode we'd
have to like sing a song with her right
yeah no that's a dream guess because I
think that's who our listeners want to
hear from and we all have so many
questions for her
and it's like what podcast is gonna be
the best place for Miss Rach to tell her
truth other than the toast
nowhere you couldn't have a better match
you couldn't dream up a better collab
you really couldn't
you really oh I just saw the message
that's so so exciting
yeah so kind of like big things
happening at the toes not to brag or
anything big things for Littles
dead
um so we've got a great show should we
dive in sure
still no update on Miss Jennifer Shaw
just keeping everyone in the loop thank
you so much without further Ado here are
the past five stories that you need to
know
and today's episode is brought to you by
bowl and Branch Bolin branch is simply
everything of the sort
however you're spending the winter
season make sure you're getting your
best sleep with a set of buttery soft
sheets from Bowling Branch made with the
softest 100 organic cotton you've ever
felt it's the kind of quality you'll
feel immediately Jackie and I both have
been singing the Praises of bowling
Branch my house Jackie's house my guest
room at Jackie's house all bowling
Branch we all have the signature hem
sheets it's their best seller and for a
reason they use the highest quality
threads on Earth they're made from slow
grown organic cotton for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep they
have tons of positive reviews online
they're beloved even by three U.S
presidents
um they come in all different colors
sizes they go from Twin to California
King Ivy king bed fits perfectly I love
to get better with every wash it really
is the time of year to like reinvest in
your bed it's winter we're spending a
lot of time at home get yourself a set
of sheets from Bowling branch and then
also shop their accessories like I have
a lot of pillows and throw blankets from
Bolin Branch extremely Chic and rached
parcel approved make the most of bedtime
with bowl and bread sheets get 15 off
your first shed of oh get 15 off your
first set of sheets when you use promo
code toast at bowl and branch.com that's
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast
t-o-a-s-t I also gave Boll and Branch um
to a few people as gifts over the
holidays and when I tell you like you
really can't give a better gift than the
gift of like sleep and comfort and and
love and it was it was so appreciated so
just a little hack if you need to get
for someone today's episode is also
sponsored by Thrive Market our go-to for
all of our grocery and household
essentials and the convenience of
getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorsteps is a huge Time Saver I saw on
your Instagram that you just got a huge
shipment from Thrive Market tell us
about some of your favorite products I
totally will I got a huge shipment from
Thrive Market I was saying like I don't
know why I got my license because I
could just shop online at dive market
and they have literally everything they
have healthy versions of so many
different things I stocked up my pantry
with like cooking ingredients you know
how sometimes you just need like the
most random thing for a recipe and like
you have to go to the store for each
individual thing like now I am stocked
for anything a recipe might call for
they have such good baby food and baby
food brands the ones that I already use
for Harry they have on Thrive market so
it just makes it so easy to get them all
in one place and of course I mean your
girl's gotta eat I got such tasty tasty
snacks I don't know if this is your Vibe
but I got um truffle potato chips like
truffle chips I've tried it so good
especially if you're having like people
over you put out a bowl because it's not
something you can eat like you know you
don't need them like regular chips but
they're like so refined and tasty just
that's a tip of the day yeah Thrive
Market has like options they're not like
other stores like they really have a
such a good curation of of snacks
specifically and when you're a Thrive
Market member you can save money on
every single order so on average you're
saving over 30 each time they also um
are really like killing the filter game
like when you are looking for something
the way you can filter through products
whether you're looking for like
gluten-free whatever your dietary like
restrictions are they make filtering
down so easy and simple yeah I like to
sometimes filter by just vegetarian that
way I'm not seeing like meat products
that I'm not gonna have and it's such an
easy way to shop
you can join Thrive market today and get
30 off your first order plus a free 60
gift when you go to thrivemarket.com the
toast for 30 off your first order plus
that free 60 gift that's t-h-r-i-v-e
market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast oh and it
came so quickly and it comes so quickly
love to see it oh my God just like hack
now I can spend my time like in the car
doing something fun like perhaps getting
a manicure for the first time in three
months
oh I got a manicure yesterday
um you know I've noticed like with your
new life and being a mom and like having
actually important things to do
um you have definitely stopped your your
manicure cycle and I find the manicure
cycle so toxic like let me tell you how
that's a part of motherhood I'm looking
forward to like not giving a [ __ ] about
just getting off the ride and just
making sure that they just like look
nice I stopped clear and healthy like I
used to try and get a manicure down here
like try and get a ride I couldn't
really find like a manicure place that I
loved then I went back to like doing it
myself just like how I was doing here in
covid but like still they would chip and
I just don't have the time to like be
constantly thinking about like my
chipped nails and so now I'm just going
bare
and I like it stunning I could like
stand to clip my nails right now but
just keep them you and I got just keep
them clean you and I you and I got
pedicures together when we were in
Florida and I thought that was a great
nail salon oh yeah it was just a little
far but I agree yeah that's where I'm
like dreaming of going when I'm gonna
get a manicure one day and I got a gel
pedicure that time so I won't be getting
a pedicure again for one whole year
yeah no I completely agree like with
pedicures I will not be getting a new
pedicure until my white pedicure looks
like a French manicure no until the
bottom of it is at the top
exactly except you do need to clip your
toenails if you're not going to get a
pedicure otherwise you'll get ingrown
and your shoes won't fit
for sure life hack
holes in all your socks okay our first
story some big Housewives news though
not the news that you're thinking of
Lisa arena is quote grateful as she
announces her exit from The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills after eight
seasons after eight seasons of
delivering sassy one-liners drama-filled
moments social media messiness and
self-deprecating lip humor Rina is
departing the Beloved franchise people
can exclusively confirm she told people
in a statement quote this is the longest
job I have held in my 35-year career and
I am grateful to everyone at Bravo and
all those involved in this series
it has been a fun eight-year run and I
am excited for what's to come the
decision was made is when his contract
expired at the end of last season after
weighing her options in business
obligation she and Bravo mutually
decided that she would not return to
Beverly Hills
fired
not asked back
not asked back
um
this is crazy you know Kathy we did it
Joe we did it Kathy I think the decision
for the network to like move forward the
Kathy's made it abundantly clear
publicly and I'm sure privately too she
will not be have any sort of involvement
on the show if Lisa Rinna is still
around after what went down with the
whole Aspen thing
um and it's clear that the network is
investing in Kathy so I'm curious if now
like
if they're going to get rid of Lisa
Rinna who I love her or hate her is like
really a staple of the show and moves
things around and creates drama Kathy's
gonna have to give us more I wonder if
Kathy's now a full-time housewife yeah I
also feel like there's a chance that it
wasn't just Kathy's ultimatum that made
Brina nappy ass back like the fans
really were kind of at the end of their
rope with her and I don't think it's
fair to put like all the pressure now
Kathy has to be the new Rena and stir
the pot and keep the show moving forward
no I first of all I didn't mean that I
just mean like she can't you don't get
by doing the bare minimum anymore if
they really did yes Let Go of Lisa yes I
agree that's how like it looks like okay
this you brought the job now you got it
like step up to the plate right but the
thing is like what Kathy's bare minimum
that she was bringing to the table like
that's what people wanted from one from
Kathy like I actually think if we start
to get more of her though I I do think
at this point she should be a full-time
housewife but I don't think that her
role within the girls should change
other than being just like herself
because that's what people love about
her
yeah I also I I actually don't think
that like the fans rage and booing her
at bravocon had anything to do with her
being fired like of course it's not
ideal but I think at the end of the day
if I worked in like television
production like I would ultimately see
that as a benefit like people getting
like passionately invested and everyone
every show needs a villain and and I
think probably Lisa rinna's villain Hood
was
perhaps like uh she reached new levels
for Bravo like I don't think anyone's
ever gotten booed at bravocon it's only
happened like for three years
but I still think it's good for the show
yes I agree like that inspires passion
but I do think like when you write
yourself as the villain
it's kind of a dead end
I also think what what's so interesting
about this is like how it affects the
group dynamic in terms of Erica I feel
like Eric over the last two three years
is like really kind of pigeonholed
herself with Lisa there used to be like
that Core Group Kyle to Lisa Erica and I
feel like that's very much like
dissolved and I wonder what this means
for Erica like and her relationships
with the other women because she doesn't
have this crutch anymore yeah she's
gonna have to forge new friendships
which ultimately might be good for her
because she they were kind of siled the
two of them and like miserable together
yeah so it could ultimately be good now
Lisa Vanderpump tweeted ding dong and I
think people think it's because like
ding dong the witch is dead
yeah when I first read it I thought it
was like ding dong like she's ringing
the doorbell like she's showing up
no okay I was open to different
interpretations but I don't see that at
all like ding dong I'm ready to come
back no real that's I don't know why
that's where my head went but now that
it's there I'm like maybe it's time to
bring back Lisa Vanderpump
I'm ready as a former hater I hate her
ready
I also think it's worth noting that I
don't think Lisa's relationship with the
network is done like I do think she'll
still be at events Bravo kind of things
should be on watch weapons live it's
just like a celebrity I think like they
they keep they weirdly keep some people
like close like Teddy Mellencamp was
just on watch weapons live granted she
came with her dad John Cougar Mellencamp
but still like she is she's been on
since multiple times since she was let
go so they keep certain people like in
the fold like even how all the Shahs of
Sunset were at bravocon and their show
was canceled like I think Lisa will
still be like a friend of the network
yeah in a way that not everyone is but
that's also because she's just a
celebrity
right but also now it's interesting like
where does Lisa rinna's career go from
here because you know Housewives I think
really gave her like a new wave in her
career she was this like
kind of like a relevant like not I don't
like to use the term washed up but like
in terms of her acting career yeah like
it wasn't paying the bills and keeping
the mansion in Malibu afloat and I think
Housewives money-wise and fame wise like
really reinvigorated her career and I'm
curious what she does with that now I
think she might manage her daughters
and just be like a professional Mama
jerk yeah and she'll like go to all the
yeah just be like Chris yeah
and then and like an influencer
everything with them
that's interesting I like that I think
that'd be good for her yeah
that's my guess
interesting but your guess is as good as
mine
but sometimes because she's a worker bee
yeah she's a hustle hustle hustle in
terms of Ding Dong I am open to the
interpretation that perhaps it's a ding
dong like a bell I didn't think about a
doorbell but I don't know I'm not
getting behind the meaning of like her
ready to come back like if it was a
doorbell what else could it mean like
ding dong
no I'm sorry it's totally Ding Dong The
Witch Is Dead like let's not waste our
time I'm just saying that's where my
head went and I just thought I would
share
no I'm glad you did because my like
literally didn't even go there and
that's definitely like an obvious
reference yeah
so
it's bittersweet the news
no I know like even though I was so
anti-rina and I was like very much here
for like Kathy winning I've cooled off
no and something about her leaving it's
like well like she's the worst but she
makes the show great yeah
my strong feelings had cooled off I
didn't need this news now I could have
gone into another season and with you
know tabula rasa
I completely agree like it's too much
time has passed now she kind of looks
like the victim
damn
how the tables have turned
so true are you ready for our next story
because it's some really wonderful news
after news that we shared earlier this
week about Demar Hamlin he has begun to
awaken he's moving his hands and feet Dr
say Buffalo Bill safety Demar Hamlin is
beginning to awaken as he shows quote
substantial Improvement in his recovery
from going into cardiac arrest and
collapsing on the field during Monday's
game doctors at the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center said on
Thursday one of the doctors said Hamlin
is still considered critically ill and
that significant progress is needed
Hamlin's neurological condition appears
to be intact the doctor said fabulous he
said he's able to move his hands and
feet and he is unable to speak but was
able to communicate in writing they said
that I wonder why he can't speak
I don't know maybe because of some of
the stuff they've got
going on
um like maybe he has like a tube
I don't know it could be just like
logistic like that
um right it is said that he asked
whether the bills won Monday night's
game against the Bengals
um and then the doctor responded quote
the answer is yes tomorrow you won you
won the game of life
so everyone is like sharing this like so
cute
um
I just want to say like I'm so happy
Demar Hamlin hopefully will be okay that
he's awake it was so I was talking about
it on good guys and and Josh was like
really
putting into perspective like the odds
of this happening like for this sort of
condition to happen it's like your heart
has to be pumping at the exact moment uh
that it hits something like it was so
rare we don't know what the exact thing
that happened was like people are
speculating there's this like really um
rare heart disease that starts with a c
that people are saying like that's what
it was something yeah Como chorditis
yeah but no doctor has confirmed that Oh
I thought it was like confirmed that's
what it was I haven't seen a
confirmation
I'm just seeing like people speculating
um so I'm so and like I feel like people
is in sports and pop culture just all
over the world have like really come
together to Rally around him the money
that was raised is incredible
um
but I am not 100 believing that the
first thing he said was did we win the
game I'm sure eventually once he came
too and what happened and where's my mom
like I'm sure after that he's like oh
wait did we win that game but this like
the first thing he said I don't believe
it I know I feel like it's just a really
nice story and this is something I think
the whole country has just been on edge
the last few days and so it's a nice
anecdote especially the doctor saying
you run the game of life like it's
giving Hallmark movies yeah but it's
it's giving like a little
not believable
yeah no like it's sweet and I love that
they're giving us like a storybook
ending
um
and I'm sure at one point after he woke
up he asked whatever happened with the
game yeah it's natural but when you
experience like a major medical trauma
and you're in a coma like you're
resuscitated like you don't remember
certain things I I just don't believe
the first thing he wrote down did we win
yeah they didn't say it was the first
thing they said they were that he woke
up and he asked did we win that doesn't
mean that it was a first but they're
definitely punishing forth this like
really sweet story that I just don't
find entirely
because here are a list of things that
he probably said before he asked where
am I what happened what happened who are
you
why does my chest hurt where's my family
what day is it yeah
a million things yeah
so it's nice and it is nice and I'm not
trying to be negative and I and I just
want to say like Demar Hamlin has my
full love and support the way the way I
didn't know who this man was before and
now like I will be following him and
like I love the bills
but let's be real with one another he
said it maybe a couple hours later yeah
also it's not like he's the one who's
telling the press in the media that
that's this was the conversation like
someone else is like writing this story
no this like PR department for the bills
like yeah it's like they really I think
they want to inspire people and uplift
people it's beautiful it's beautiful but
I think it's only half true I agree
I'm so glad that he is up I hope he
makes like a speedy fast easy recovery
and I'm just wishing him the best I
really am agree but I do think he has a
long word ahead of him because they
still saying critically ill but the fact
that I think neurologically it seems as
though he is doing well is is extremely
important huge yeah so that is some
great news to add into the weekend after
what was really a great week and
harrowing starts agreed and the new
upgrade
agreed so you agree or no
kind of in agreement with you you know
I'm not sure though we'll Circle back
we'll Circle back for sure I'm in
agreement there as well are you ready
for our next story
I'm so agreeable today you are you're
always agreeable
oh yeah that's what people say about me
they say that Claudia she's so agreeable
never talks back
never never is a contrarian never is
contentious
no not mcclurgia
not my mcclures a hernia not the Arizona
mclartials
uh I'm wishing him the best in their
game this week
are they a football team or baseball
team
such good questions you ask I'm fairly
certain it's the St Louis Cardinals St
Louis no St Louis Cardinals and I only
know that because it's Andy Cohen's
favorite team
the word I'm sorry the name Louis Lewis
is literally going to be the death of
you
it's so true Louis from One Direction no
Lewis no
Louie Louie
Louie judice yep
Saint Saint Louis
no Meet Me In St Louis
no that the movie Sex in the City [ __ ]
up that movie Louise from St Louis
is it ever pronounced Lewis I feel like
when it's spelled l-e-w-i-s
wait what do you mean it's always
pronounced Lewis
Vuitton
you ever call it Louis Vuitton
no but Louis Vuitton is Italian I live
in America [ __ ] okay it's Lewis for
what Saint Louis
Saint Louis stop saying Saint Louis
let's just Google it
and also like a lot of a lot of you know
American places are named after European
places
but maybe we change the pronunciation
with our accents
how to say St Louis
it's St Louis I've been there
St Louis Louis
Missouri
confuse me more
it's St Louis it's Louis Tomlinson
and it's
Louis Capaldi Lewis Capaldi my fave I
think Lewis Capaldi is e-w-i-s my brain
can't handle this conversation moving on
yeah that's just going to be one of
those things that is never solved for me
what story is this number three
okay we still have time still no gen cha
I keep checking okay well we have a
fifth Story backup just in case
okay Victoria Beckham is defending her
son Brooklyn after his cooking video is
dividing fans
oh my God not like the way the Chokehold
that Brooklyn Beckham's fake culinary
career has on our culture is something
that brings me immense Joy yeah so
Brooklyn is under Fire again for some of
his cooking he showed for cosplaying and
appropriating as a chef no that's not
why
um he did a video where he was joined by
Michelin former Michelin Chef Kevin Lee
and they took on the traditional British
Sunday Rose but with the twist he showed
fancy ingredients used to create the
meal and he treated fans to a sneak peek
of the end result but to his surprise
the video didn't go over too well with
fans who said the meat looked raw and
undone one critic joke that the me a
good vet could bring the meat back to
life like he's holding a slab of meat
that looks completely raw and he says he
says that's the finished product that's
the finished product so Jackie maybe it
was that technique people are doing
where they like have like huge errors in
their videos in order to create
engagement like how you always say when
your mic flag is turned upside down we
get so many the comments that it's
upside down and engagement is engaged
right people that's what people do
especially on The Talk
no and I've been seeing ever since you
pointed it out for me I've been seeing
it everywhere like you know the luggage
company base yes
over the holidays they had this um
it was a paid ad so like when you would
scroll through Tick Tock you would see
bass and it was like showing you how to
wrap the base travel bag like this
duffel bag for the holidays if you got
it for someone and they wrapped it like
[ __ ] like literally like the ugliest
[ __ ] rapping of all time but like it
looked like it was serious up until the
end and the comments were like oh
someone's getting fired and I think it
was on purpose yeah no I've seen that a
lot recently like we were talking about
I guess Emily Mariko made a pie that was
like really jiggly disgusting one of my
friends were saying that they think that
she did it like to provoke people and
get it generated also um then I fell for
this like for literally years but Abby
Hebert and how she says on her Instagram
that she's cousins with Noah back I
literally thought until last week that
they were cousins
that's a thing people do on Tick Tock
they're like oh I'm here with my
stepbrother and then it's like another
tick tocker and all the comments like
wait I missed a chapter but it's just a
way to create engagement I just took it
at face value and then also she also
calls her daughter you're too honest for
this life she calls her daughter she's
like my 20 month old daughter on Tick
Tock or on Rails and you know that like
really bothers people when people talk
about their kids like that
so for that one I actually don't think
she's like no but now that you told me
that she said no Beck's her cousin and
he's not like I know she's [ __ ] with
us like there is a girl on Tick Tock I
don't follow her but she does like Mom
content like breastfeeding she like
always comes up and she talks about her
kid and she says her kid's name is poot
yeah that's Abby
no it's a different girl no she calls
her daughter pooped oh maybe I'm getting
my mom talkers confused okay she does
poop and then another girl like says her
her daughter's name is like Robert or
something like
just and I think she doesn't want to
share her kid's name but like also to
create like fodder for people to discuss
it's really smart we gotta start doing
wacky [ __ ] like every time you pronounce
like the car company Hyundai don't
correct me
no correct you no you don't correct me
yeah yeah we got to start being more
clickbaity like I'm sorry we have built
a brand off of honesty and authenticity
and look where it's gotten us not know
where we should be
agree except we're numbers
um so much for honestly yeah
[Music]
yeah our first episode back hit number
three on the comedy podcast charts and
usually we peek at like five or six so
every time we like if we even hit four
we're like oh my God so three was like
really big especially considering it's
not like it wasn't our first episode
ever
no and it wouldn't we really should
should have been in number two but I
guess people found the episode about the
tragic murder of someone named Pamela so
funny that they were number two and I'm
glad people are finding murder funny
crime girls are not [ __ ] okay no
they're not I have so many things to say
about that but the first thing I will
say is that you can't judge that until
the podcast I've never listened you have
to listen to it
I know I just think optically for their
brand they should be removed from the
comedy section one because then we would
move up in the charts and two like I
don't think that's what they would want
to put forward people thinking that
these girls think crime is funny there's
nothing funny about crime just ask Jen
Shaw okay that's not even a good
reference because there's difference
between like you know swindling people
and murder jacket forgive me for just
trying to be topical like murder
no for sure there's nothing funny about
crime just ask
you know a victim of any crime
that's really poignant
powerful um
but you have to listen to the podcast to
understand what they're doing there and
how it could be in comedy no I'm sure I
would giggle but I just still think
if you're going to get into the True
Crime space and you're going to be the
leader of it like you definitely have
like an ethical responsibility to like
not commercialize it and like still be
respectful and I'm sure that they do and
I've heard that like a lot of the big
True Crime podcasts you know give back
they work with the families yada yada I
just think like you know this shouldn't
be in comedy it's a little disrespectful
that's all I'm saying even if it is a
funny show yeah but maybe they have a
reason for being in comedy that's like
you know
I think the reason is probably that
they're funny girls and I love funny
girls okay but it reminded me because in
the book but I'm just sorry I'm also
just selfishly like get out of the get
out of the way genre so I can move my
ass up yeah that's why I just want to be
perfectly clear about my intentions yeah
but in the book we just read for the
redheads the it girl it's like about a
crime obviously and she's one of um she
was like the best friend of the person
who was murdered and she talks about
like the impact all these podcasts have
and how she like [ __ ] hates them
of course yeah they're just like so
invasive and they just like require you
to like live through it again and again
again that's just one fictional girl's
perspective
so true but not doesn't make it any less
important that she doesn't exist this
would actually be a great segue into our
next story except that we didn't finish
talking about this story
what was the story Victoria Beckham is
defending Brooklyn oh so what did she
say so she said it's rare people not raw
okay go off Queen
um the way this is so
inconsequential to like the things going
on in the world and
I can't even muster up a response like I
don't like I don't [ __ ] care like
yeah I mean Brooklyn there's people that
are like Brooklyn didn't do this you
know it's the people who are constantly
coming for him I
I he kind of like really puts himself in
these unfortunate situations yeah
um with the cooking with the cooking
he's also like
textbook Napo baby I was just you
literally took the words out of my mouth
and now I'm realizing we did it on the
patreon so if you guys haven't listened
we recapped that whole netball baby
article I don't believe the beckhams
were included in that yeah and so but I
also feel like it's because Nikolai I
also feel like they weren't included in
that because aside from him like
cosplaying as a chef like it's not like
he's tried to work in the industry and
got jobs because of who his parents were
like we're just following him because
he's a kid of David and Victoria that's
actually so true and if it weren't for
him try to like break it into the
culinary field like he really isn't a
nepo baby like he doesn't he's famous
because his parents are famous but
you're right he's not in the industry at
all Nicola is an EPO but she's in the
industry she like directs and acts and
yes and she has no she has no right to
like you know yeah
so then when they have kids what's that
nepo to the Third
it's Grant and nepotism Grand yeah but
it's like not just your grandparents
being Stars your parents being right
you're a second generation nepo baby
yeah
yeah that's like um Billy Lord
exactly
and from what I learned from the article
was like a lot of people had like
grandparents yeah because well because
they're like it just keeps going you
know yeah The Offspring of nepo babies
are still nepo babies and they're like
the parents were successful because
they're in that boat then they can't
have the kid yeah blah blah blah it's a
vicious cycle
anyways
um
it was raw rare not raw do it that way
you will but I'm just I'm glad to see
that Victoria's still like defending him
even though there's so much
trouble in Paradise
a mother's love Mother's love knows no
bounds nothing like a toxic
mother-in-law
she's got I would she's got my respect
I would pay big bucks to really know
what's going on with that family like it
intrigues me to the nth degree yeah
I'm sure and we'll never know maybe you
could find out someone maybe someone
will DM you something you could ask
dumwa but she knows maybe I'll ask
around when I'm in La like just people
on the street I'll be one of those
Street interviewers what do you know
about Nicola and the Peltz family yeah
Peltz Beckham okay our next story
something that we have is this four it's
a fourth I'm moving as slowly as
possible
I know I'm sorry is it the four story
that's brought to you by uh perfect bar
yes
are you looking for delicious and
nutritious snack well look no further
than perfect bar with their lineup of
fresh from the fridge protein bars
perfect bar is exactly what you and your
family need made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars and little
snack size bars too that are all so good
and good for you you are sure to find a
flavor that you love my personal
favorite and you guys know I'm a picky
eater but I love the dark chocolate chip
peanut butter that has a little sprinkle
of sea salt it is perfection it is
delicious delicious and has become my
go-to I'm actually taking one from the
studio throwing it in my purse for my
flight because it's a long flight and I
gotta stay full they have a cookie dough
texture it's creamy and full of flavor
and they're unlike any other bars out
there they now come in snack size
they're packed with up to six grams of
protein and 150 calories a little goes a
long way with these bars perfect bar
knows that it'll be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time they're offering
you a chance to try their refrigerated
protein bars for free here's how it
works sign up for email or text and
upload a picture of your receipt eat
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or your PayPal account which is
pretty cool all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com
t-o-a-s-t to get a free perfect bar
today happy snacking enjoy a protein bar
that's in the fridge because its
ingredients are fresh and that just
makes sense today's episode is also
brought to you by rocket money say
goodbye to last year's outdated
disorganized methods of managing your
money and say hello to Rocket money the
better way to hack your finances in 2023
rocket money formerly known as true bill
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
that they forgot about like that
streaming service you bought to watch
just one show on or that free trial that
you never even used rocket money will
quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones that you don't want
with the New Year being here I feel like
a lot of people's resolutions used to be
like more financially healthy and get
their finances in order and having an
app like rocket money is so helpful
especially from the subscription
standpoint like you don't even know how
many like how you easily just like
autofill your credit card on all these
things and you never realized I think
you've been charged like two dollars a
month for a year it's so dumb let rocket
money help you over three three million
people have used rocket money and the
average person saves up to 720 a year
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com toast that's rocket
r-o-c-k
ET
money.com slash toast rocketmoney.com
t-o-a-s-t they make canceling
subscriptions as easy as the in the
click of a button simply find the
subscription you don't want press cancel
and Rocket money will do all the work in
canceling it for you there's no long
hold times with customer service and
tedious emailing back and forth check it
out great thank you so much mclared
you're welcome okay our next story is
something that is
taking the nation by storm we have not
spoken about this yet but you know it's
a Friday so we have the time to delve
into this and things are really we're
starting to get information so the Idaho
murders that took place uh late last
year
the suspected killer had been arrested
on December 30th and charged with four
counts of murder in connection with the
stabbing deaths of four University of
Idaho students and yesterday the
affidavit was made public of what
evidence they had to arrest this guy so
the shocking killings of four University
of Idaho students left the town of
Moscow Idaho on edge for nearly seven
weeks while authorities searched for a
killer on Friday after remaining
tight-lipped over the course of the
initial investigation authorities
announced that Brian coburger 28 was
arrested in Pennsylvania and charged
with four counts of murder and one count
of felony burglary in connection with
the stabbing deaths of Madison Mogan
Taylor gun clavis Zanna Coronado and
Ethan Chapin on January 3rd coburger
waved his extradition and he was
transported to Idaho on January 4th his
preliminary hearing while he will enter
a plea to the charges against him is
scheduled for January 12th now that he
is back in Idaho the probable cause
affidavit has been released shedding
light on what it led investigators to
arrest co-burger so this is so
interesting because for literally seven
weeks actually until they arrested him
like it felt like they were they had
nothing I was following this oh well if
the detectives on Tick Tock had solved
it already that's part of the reason I
haven't really spoken about this and
this is my general sentiment towards
True Crime especially as it happens in
real time like Gabby Patito the way
people are so [ __ ] out of control on
social media like it's so disrespectful
like when you see pictures of these like
four young kids who died it's like it's
so sad these are college kids who are
just regular kids and I think the way
the internet handles like True Crime is
so inappropriate and so disrespectful
and like that's why a lot of times like
I don't keep up with these cases because
it's very difficult to see people being
so blatantly disrespectful when like
literally a young person has died four
yeah agreed um I think that the
sheriff's what it seemed like for seven
weeks that they didn't really have any
leads I feel like they were being
extremely tight-lipped this is just some
of the theories that I've seen so that
like nothing leaked and that that he had
no idea idea that they were on to him I
even think that yeah so there was we
know now what led to his arrest
according to the affidavit which has
been reviewed by People magazine a
sheath of the knife so like the cover of
the like when you have a knife like you
put a cover on it yeah a sheath of a
knife used in the stabbings was left at
the scene in the bed where Mogan and
goncalves were found deceased this is
where detectives found DNA linking
coburger according to the affidavit
agents took trash from his parents home
in Pennsylvania to test for a DNA match
the documents allege also according to
the affidavit one of the surviving
roommates said they saw the killer
dressed in the affidavit as quote a
figure clad in Black clothing and a mask
who walked past her as he left the crime
scene and she heard crying on the night
of the killings he was linked to the
crime scene from DNA and cell phone
pings the affidavit alleged so alleged
so they also had this car that was like
seen leaving the area of the crime scene
that night and they like Trace camera
footage to get the license plate so I
think that's what star started it they
traced the license plate to him then
they got trash from his parents house
and you can collect DNA off of trash
because it's forfeited property
I just
I this is so baller the way the uh the
Idaho Police Department handled this
like with not a peep being leaked to the
media going to Pennsylvania going
through the trash like this is such good
police work like
to the police like this is a like really
incredible in getting like a [ __ ]
Delirious psychotic killer psychotic
violent killer like not shooting
stabbing like violent evil [ __ ]
twisted [ __ ] this is yesharkawa I
don't know what the English translation
for yesterday good job job well done but
like heartier than that he also was a
student studying criminal justice and
criminology it's also still unclear what
the connection is if any between him and
these students and I'm sure more will
come out over the trial and as we learn
more this is just like the first bit of
information that we've received but also
did you see that so he was driving with
his dad in the car
to Pennsylvania and he was stopped twice
on the way like uh traffic yeah I saw
body cam funny and those I at first I
think people we all thought like oh what
a coincidence and they have like this
stuff when he was on the run but those
were like coordinated to get images of
his hands
from the traffic stops so they were like
hailing him until they had the evidence
that they needed to arrest him this is
um it's just amazing police work like
it's so it's like you know you see CSI
and SVU and then you learn from actual
law enforcement like it's never like
that you know it takes takes months to
get a fingerprint and this is some real
like CSI magic like it's so it's so
brilliant it's so amazing and it's
they're doing such a like a service to
the families of these kids I do have
questions like I don't understand the
connection between Brian and these kids
and nobody does but how do you go into a
house with six people with the intent to
stab four of them and then he left do
you not see the other two yeah so two
were still alive one of them saw him
it's unclear if he saw her and left her
alive and if he did why did he do that
also that other student roommate who saw
him like didn't call the police for
several hours I think people are really
confused by that too so
um I'm sure we'll learn more
yeah and I don't want to I don't want to
jump to any conclusions no I'm sure this
person is traumatized beyond beyond no I
definitely I saw the I think it was like
eight hours like a long time was wait
before the police was called and I said
I'm like oh that's interesting my gut in
my initial reaction is not to uh blame
her her literally her entire house of
friends was just stabbed like I'm sure
there's a perfectly logical explanation
and I look forward to hearing it yeah
also then they have like cell phone
pings that they like now that once he
became the prime suspect then other
things started to fall into line so like
he turned his phone off at the time of
the murder so that his phone couldn't be
traced to cell phone towers which is
like something a criminal justice
student would probably know to do but
then his phone was seen in the area
again that next morning like five hours
later at nine a.m I don't know if he
like left something he went back to the
scene of the crime and then he probably
wanted to see like what was that I also
I like started following uh Instagram
account that's just like updating us on
the story
um Avast Davids are typically like
pretty um all of the like basic evidence
that was needed to arrest this person
but then like there will be more because
now that they they are like then they
can look into his social media they can
look into they can do a whole thing
um
but this is the the big stuff of how
they led to him which I I do think is
pretty incredible
it's incredible
um this is such a terrible story and I
think
I always just get like so
like grossed out when certain cases I
don't know what it is about like Gabby
Patito because stuff like this happens
all the time but like certain cases like
catch the attention of the nation and I
think the way people behave is like
sometimes really abhorrent and
disrespectful so
um
it's just like a really it's a terrible
story just for you know college kids
like young kids who are like their whole
lives are ahead of them stabbed in their
house in their sleep like it's it's
[ __ ] terrible and I literally I wish
the worst for this man I
I hate this man yeah it's horrible for
their families I think it's terrible
it's very difficult to go through like
obviously a tragedy grief and then the
added element of like people on social
media like literally come into your
house like stop oh yeah of course but I
think also now being able to have a
suspect and there's less issues like
what happened here because for so many
weeks it felt like there was no leads
I think it's it's huge and I just
majorly hope that Justice is served
me too
um [ __ ] this man like every which way
yeah
for our fifth and final story which is
looking like it won't be Jen shot
sentencing nope nothing okay well the
same but different Nicole Kidman is set
to star in Yellowstone creators upcoming
CIA drama lioness
so Nicole Kidman that was a mouthful
Nicole Kidman is working with Tyler
Sheridan Taylor
on Paramount Plus's upcoming CIA drama
called lioness so it's not part of the
Yellowstone family okay but we love
ourselves a little Taylor Sheridan and
so does Nicole Kidman apparently she is
going to be producing on the project
which she was to begin with but now
she's also set to star in the series
it I feel like this came about because
like her and Keith Urban probably just
like really like Yellowstone yeah so she
just like was probably at a dinner party
with the man that she respected yeah and
we worked together first it was like oh
we'll produce and then maybe they needed
a lead character and it's like well
you're the kind of the greatest actress
I know totally and then maybe you could
play Caitlyn Mead the veteran CIA senior
supervisor who struggles with her
personal and professional life balance
as well as mentoring someone who is
eerily following in her same steps
and now maybe like next season like
Keith Urban has like a very brief stint
on Yellowstone you know this season they
had lady Wilson and Zach Bryan more like
under not unknown but like still up and
comers but if they had Keith Urban like
that'd be pretty sick yeah that would be
really sick
let's hold out hope just an idea but in
the meantime I love this
yeah I feel like everything thus far we
have seen from Taylor Sheridan is
nothing less than gorgeous and Nicole
Kidman putting her stamp of approval on
something like you know her last couple
of shows the undoing I didn't like it
and I'm perfect strangers but people did
uh big little lies like she really she
kills it in the TV space yeah did you
finish nine perfect strangers no
I couldn't even make it past episode
maybe I think I think episode two is
when we actually meet Nicole Kidman and
the second I heard her accent I turned
it off it was so bad
no thank you
no thank you
um but what I'm saying is like these two
are pretty much like guaranteed to make
good [ __ ] yeah he has a really cult
following so does she I mean I'm in the
Venn diagram I'll be watching this
yeah no it's definitely not the collab
you would have expected yeah
but it's the one we got and nonetheless
I'm thrilled ditto and then I don't know
that any of his shows really get
nominated for the big accolades
Yellowstone never not in the way that
you would think maybe they finally got
nominee but they've never swept like
it's the show the whole country's
watching and like they the award shows
don't reflect that right I feel like
with her they love her
maybe this is his way of like kind of
getting his foot in the door with like
Hollywood Elite yeah
because he's like a down-home country
boy yeah but this could be the show that
gets him those nominations
what's Taylor Sheridan's like personal
life like I think that he is a cowboy
I don't know I'm sorry is he married he
is married and that and his wife is who
Beth is based on apparently she's like a
fast talking Queen like best stop
that's so cute it's really cute
what's his wife's name
um I think her name is Nicole yeah
Nicole
Nicole Weir Brook there was married
since 2013 and she's absolutely gorgeous
and what does she do for work like is
she
in the industry she
um
she has an impressive career of her own
says Hollywood Life
and that career is that
she is a model and an actress
nice does she have everything in
Yellowstone no I don't think so
her first gig was on How I Met Your
Mother she also played a role in the
film The Human contract she was in the
TV did she have like a big role on how I
may rather like an extra they don't say
Hollywood Life didn't say
um interesting well seems as though you
know your wife is an actress you have a
number one show in the country you put
yourself on your show all the time
Travis right she's also an equestrian
and competes and Company cutting
competitions including the 2020 charity
Foundation celebrity cutting event where
she received top honors so she is a
cowgirl too
no it's so authentic that's why the show
is so good yeah so I think he's
immensely inspired by her and that's why
Beth is so awesome
that's great I'd love to I love that me
too art imitating life well we are at
the end of the show still no Jensen news
so the I'm sure the verdict will come
the moment the show ends but that just
means we have someone to talk about on
Monday when I'm in L.A
so reminder if you're on the west coast
perfect because we're going to be
recording on West Coast time if you're
on the East Coast episodes will be out
later next week that's the price you pay
when you're a fabulous Starlet in
Hollywood you know young Hollywood queen
totally they'll probably be out an hour
later than usual so not we we're still
recording earlier I'm waking up early
recording earlier than usual but like
within you know reason for McClurg girls
got to sleep
so just bear with us while it'll
probably be an hour an hour and a half
later than it's usually up
but it's been a great week it's been so
good to be back I have enjoyed this
immensely thank you guys for being so
excited about the toast coming back it
feels good to you know
to be missing to not feel like you know
it's like an echo chamber you know there
are people listening it's not yes they
are so hope everyone has a great day and
a great weekend do something special for
yourself but sometimes something for you
sometimes self-care looks like hard work
but maybe not this weekend
maybe not
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know everybody Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as practicing where podcasts can be
found on Spotify gym Stitch Republic
video I already guess Box about the
places we've listened podcast
Mario hope you guys have it in cleob
weekend and we will see you in LA on
Monday
and we love you bye